[Musik]
ich kenne salome jetzt schon seit vier
jahren sie war 14 und im vierten monat
schwanger meine eigenen kinder waren
damals noch klein und ich wusste was es
bedeutet sich die nächte mit weinenden
babys um die ohren zu schlagen
wie muss das erst für einen teenager
sein wie ist es wenn kinder kinder
kriegen das wollte ich herausfinden und
besuchte salome fortan regelmäßig
[Musik]
und so war damals angefangen
wer schon mal hat er mir einfach 14
kaserne zügig
weitere sie
machen damit sich und
machen sich die teams laufen und dann
wie hexal passiert
wie vor hätte dich für blogger das weiß
sie nicht einig
ich denke dass diese erste maxi
salome ist das älteste der drei kinder
von samuel und dorothea die jetzt mit 40
und 41 jahren großeltern werden
trixi und fdp sie also
wieso
denn wir sind schon ziemlich perplex
nach
dem positiven schwangerschaftstest war
das weitere vorgehen für salome vorerst
klar ihr freund der 18 jährige vater des
ungeborenen kindes hatte sich per sms
von ihr getrennt und sie hatte nicht die
geringste lust sein kind auszutragen
ihre eltern aktive mitglieder einer
evangelischen freikirche gingen mit
salome den ganzen weg bis zum
schwangerschaftsabbruch
der termin im spital stand schon fest
was würde eigentlich rein theoretisch
metro vor
istrien die idee
25 du kannst einfach viel mehr sicht ist
das labor otto tätig hatte sie bei der
mieterin alaba wenn zahlen
er hätte ja
also ich muss sagen der gedanke
das ist das erste enkelkind
gebracht worden ich finde ich schlimmer
als das mir halt jetzt der mehraufwand
und der vierte lebendig gering denn das
spiel vorbei zahlen
können entscheide das müssen wir
das thema schneiderstraße während die
befugnis und zeigen wir machen beides
kann mit dir
salome hat zwei geschwister die um ein
jahr jüngere schwester leonie und den
zehnjährigen timon auch tageskind helena
gehört momentan zur familie
salome geht in die zweite sieg heute
wurden in der schule alle klassen über
die schwangerschaft informiert
also kann ich mich immer gut mit
doch erstaunlich aber was ich da
eigentlich tue was ich gedacht
es kommt alles geschaffen
hatte ging an peter schep wurde so aber
noch warten wollen erzählt
hat
das ist
also eher skepsis nicht ab ob er sich
gemacht hat
im kleinen reihenhaus beginnen die
vorbereitungen für die ankunft ist noch
in familienmitgliedes
sollten wohl nach der ehrung ich würde
den dauer links heike makk hersteller
und r8 wird noch als baby pille mccoy
und den arbeiter vor wickelkommode
mbabi dass
die
salome ist im neunten monat seit der
schwangerschaft sind die bande zwischen
mutter und älteste tochter enger
geworden salome will dass ihre mutter
dorothea sie bei der geburt unterstützt
im geburtsvorbereitungskurs ist die
15-jährige mit abstand die jüngste
häufung nicht sich komisch konnte aber
dann hat man sich diesmal in ägypten
juli verboten
durch
das ist jetzt kein problem
noch zwei wochen bis zum geburtstermin
eine anstrengende zeit liegt hinter
salome
das habe ich einfach viel liegt im
rokoko
gesichtsbuch gesichter wie alt ist hier
aber
ich habe eigentlich zwei jungs von der
stelle gesagt dass ich eine nebenstraße
jetzt trotzdem immer gegangen und
vom vater des kindes hat salome nichts
mehr gehört die vaterschaft hat er in
der zwischenzeit an r kommt
die kleine giulia ist da geboren am 12
august 2009
ihre geburt ist schlimm maximini 13
ich hätte also selber lieber selber
geboren wie wir sie zur lage wie es
einfach so schwierig ist
ja
japanische krise k während der geburt
was kaiser hat sich zwei stunden lang
mit vorwärtsgang
das 38 hektar war ja was wird das noch
zehn stunden
während der
zwölf lieder hat
[Musik]
[Applaus]
salome wollte einen südländischen namen
für ihre tochter eine kleine reminiszenz
an den kind fordert der aus mexiko
stammt und als adoptivkind in der
schweiz aufgewachsen ist gesehen hat es
ein kind bis jetzt noch nicht
[Musik]
warum zu viel
freizeit wirklich
so wurde am ende der großen schulferien
im sommer geboren nach den herbstferien
will salome ihren kurzen
mutterschaftsurlaub schon wieder beenden
und ihr letztes schuljahr beginnen um
den anschluss nicht zu verpassen macht
sie täglich hausaufgaben
und
datenbestands dass er als eine gardine
neue klassen
ja ja
der richter kann halt
georgia ist drei monate alt ihre
großmutter die hauptbezugsperson
die drei generationen familie hat ihren
rhythmus gefunden
salome geht seit einem monat wieder zur
schule zwischenmahlzeiten braucht es
jetzt für teenager und ein baby
und maschinen team ist
salome ist 15 und besucht jetzt die
dritte sekunde und klasse
zwei tage pro woche bringt sie ihre
tochter in eine kinderkrippe um ihre
mutter dorothea etwas zu entlasten
[Musik]
ich konnte wieder am 10
es ist sieben uhr in der früh in 20
minuten beginnt salomes unterricht denn
wieder ein nach der geburt von gioia hat
die jungen problemlos geschafft
10 uhr pause in der schule salome ist
schon wieder in der krippe
hätten wir dann heißt es la roja
hat eben getrunken darum salome jetzt
milch für die nächste mahlzeit abpumpen
die große pause keiner teenager mutter
in ein paar minuten geht der unterricht
weiter
[Applaus]
ein knappes jahr später besuche ich die
familie erneut georgia ist jetzt 13
monate auf
sie stand sie leer wie prächtig aber so
wie der nacht dass ich
manche stellen sie doch der
richtige start und battlestar um fünf
mal und doppelgänger ungefähr fünfmal
sie schreit noch mal 5 mal so ich mache
sogar ne metalle ja extrem
army dienen die doppel will ich damals
den schafen modifizieren dann schlaf ich
glaube und ohne schlaf für die ganze
nacht auf
den 28
[Musik]
salome ist 16 eine junge frau mitten in
der pubertät die sich naturgemäß mit
händen und füßen von ihren eltern
abgrenzen müsste wenn die mutter des
teenagers aber das kind des teenagers
betreut wird dieser ablösungsprozess
kompliziert
wenn sie da ist und ich und ich bin zum
beispiel am kochen sekte salome sie sich
jetzt sie muss jetzt jurke dann vergisst
sie sich hammel und schrieb dass sms und
dann ist ja schon wieder zwischen mine
bei
salome gemerkt hätte also denn her sie
hat innerlich die verantwortung
also sich ganz entspannt und überlaut
das eigentlich mir das
[Musik]
salome hat die schule abgeschlossen und
macht jetzt eine berufslehre aus
zeichnerin unterstützt von ihrem vater
hat seine stelle in einem
architekturbüro ganz in der nähe der
krippe gefunden salome lehrling mit kind
ganz ehrlich sagte merkel - im alter
abgeordneter so stark hustet waren sie
eben ein bisschen zählt oder vielleicht
das auf der matte darauf ist aber so
stärken wir das nicht will sich sehr gut
mit der ältere geregnet hat also immer
bezahlt habe ich das schlimmes thema
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
es braucht zwar kein ganzes dorf um die
kleine zu aufzuziehen aber immerhin eine
ganze familie samt freundin
[Gelächter]
grundton
ukraine wie vor ihrem richtiger mami
das ist er knapp aber sehr intensiv und
herzlich wenn kurz und heftig wie seit
man
aber ich denke salome die wird so wird
das sättigend rundherum mit libyen zur
wende als kurz konsum und
jojo ist dreieinhalb jahre alt noch
immer ist großmutter dorothea ihre
hauptbezugsperson
ich zeige salome ihren eltern bruder
timon und gioia die allerersten
aufnahmen für diesen film noch einmal
bilder die vor vier jahren entstanden
sind
[Musik]
noch einfacher dass die kurzschlaf dass
ich habe mir schlaflose
nacht
habe
sie qualität 420
spitze acht großen zersetzend ihr logo
versehen
salome hat jetzt einen älteren freund
der für giulia so etwas wie ein vater
ist vom biologischen vater hat sie seit
über einem jahr nichts mehr gehört der
sporadischen kontakt ist abgebrochen
immerhin er bezahlt die alimente
pünktlich
der brezn und
salome ist 18 jahre alt in diesem alter
denken andere junge frauen ans wegziehen
von zuhause für salome und ihre tochter
will ein solcher schritt reiflich
überlegt sein nicht nur wegen des
mehraufwands den ein eigener haushalt
für sie bedeuten würde wenn jetzt salome
mit ihrer durchzieht ob jetzt mit oder
ohne freunde dann ist das falsch wäre
das scheitern also einfach und verlust
und was ich denke oder was mir a strebe
das auto salome klar ist dass sie
allernächster nähe wo nick wirth zu
machen salome macht die berufsmatur
ihren eltern hat sie es zu verdanken
dass sie die ausbildung machen konnte
die sie sich immer gewünscht hat sogar
ein späteres studium steht als projekt
im raum salamis eltern werden noch lange
für sie und gioia sorgen müssen ich
frage mich ist das der preis den die
eltern zu zahlen haben weil eine
abtreibung damals für sie nicht der
richtige weg war
die familie so viel und sonst friert für
mich dazu überredet sein aber es ist
eigentlich jeder so mehr ein als ich bin
sehr froh dass ist paula und sie hat mir
nur zeigen was eigentlich richtig ist
und was gut ist höre ich sie abtreiben
gab keine depression ist natürlich die
lehrer richtig machen und damit was du
nicht willst dass du das
eigentlich hat es nie bereut aber das
problem ist ja prima dann wenn die
mega-deals duah und sich und immer
wieder und ich konnte mir ist auch
wieder machen weiß dass ich der menge 12
dann hätte mir
entschuldigt dass ich
das gemacht
vier jahre im leben von teenager mutter
salome und ihrem kind in salomes familie
bezeichnet man als geschenk als geschenk
das zwar niemand bestellt hat über das
ich aber alle von herzen freuen
[Musik]